[Music]
[Applause]
paulie was big on this story came in
yesterday and he's like did you watch
the world championships where devin
allen got disqualified from the finals
of the 110 meter hurdles because he may
have reacted too quickly
and this is the starting gun so paulie
plays it in slow motion
so this is devin allen went to oregon
this is in oregon and then they say
you're dq'd
and i went wait what did he do wrong
it's an injustice here devon allen joins
us now devin explain to me what you did
wrong getting disqualified
dan what's up um so yeah thanks for
having me um first and foremost but uh
yeah overall i think the the rule and
tracking field is uh
the threshold for reacting after the gun
is one tenth of a second so 0.1 seconds
um so you know for my reaction time at
point zero nine nine nine which is one
thousands uh too fast
um is why i got dq the crazy thing is in
the semi-final i react to that point one
zero one seconds so one one thousand
slow which is a fair start
okay once they told did you know what
you had done wrong immediately
no so when when they re recalled the
star i thought they were gonna uh you
know grant holloway the the world
champion next to me kind of goes into
set a little bit later than everyone
else so i thought they were gonna bring
us all back and tell him like hey go on
the set when we call set because it was
it was a quick gun
um but then when i got the red card in
my lane i was pretty confused so you
know obviously that's why i walked over
to the official and i wanted to see the
reactions i wanted to see the video that
they had of me starting as well so
it sounds crazy though
you it was after the gun like you it
felt like you were too good
at that is that is that a fair
assessment
i i would say that's fair overall
usually if you look at all my reaction
times i'm probably in the top
one to five percent of of all sprinters
at every competition i'm at
and so usually i'm just a quick reactor
to the gun and then
you know this weekend obviously it's a
huge competition for me world
championships in eugene oregon i'm
probably going to react a little bit
more quickly than normal um so you know
it's really unfortunate that that's
that's that's the rule i mean i
understand the rule and that's you know
it's in place so there's no false starts
but
you know not to have a little bit of
leeway for margin of error or you know
anything that goes on for our thousands
of a second kind of you know is a little
bit frustrating because i didn't get the
chance to compete
is that your last track and field event
of your career
um no no it's not going to be the last
of my career definitely the last one of
the season because i have training camp
starts on tuesday next week so i'm
actually back home in phoenix uh getting
ready getting the cleats back on running
around i'm actually
at the phoenician right now i got an
early tee time
in about 45 minutes
that's how you get ready for camp
playing golf
well you know i just need one or two
days to just decompress i've been
training really hard uh getting ready
for world champs and getting ready for
uh training camp as well so i need just
one or two days just to relax and and
enjoy phoenix the last time you played
college football was when
uh 2016 2017 season yeah right after the
2016 olympics
it's been a while can that be a good
thing that you haven't played football
in six years
i think the good thing is i haven't been
getting beat up in the nfl for six years
um and the good thing is i'm probably
the fastest and most most athletic i've
been in my my career
you know i'm much faster than i was in
college which was my strong suit when i
did play in college so
overall it's a good thing um the hard
thing is now getting back into the nfl
system and actually playing football
although i played football my whole life
um you know so i think it should be
pretty easy to get back into the swing
of it what's your role with the eagles
um i'm not really exactly sure yet
obviously my my skill set is to to kind
of stretch the field on offense and then
um on special teams i plan to do as much
as i can in the return game kick return
part return um and then on the other
side of the ball you know in terms of
special teams running down as gunner and
making tackles as well so we'll see kind
of how my role develops as i get more
comfortable on the field i expect to
have more and more of a role on the team
but you know my goal is just to go and
help the eagles win football games so
whatever that you know takes is what
i'll do
how would you do against tyreek hill
i would do pretty good now just because
i've been training and i'm pretty fast
right at this moment in time we actually
raced me and tyrique when i was in high
school i think he might have been a
senior in college
um and he beat me that race so the one
race that we did have when i was about
17 years old he beat me but right now i
think i'd get him in a race well how
fast are you how like football fast a
40-yard dash
uh
shoot well i ran a 4-3 at the pro day um
about april and that was kind of
mid-season for me
i'll probably at least a 10 faster
if not more so probably 4-2
you know if i practice it a little bit
more i would like to say 4-1 um
but you know the 40 is so difficult in
terms of like it takes a lot of skill
because a lot of fast guys you know can
run under 4-5 but then that four two to
four four range is where a lot of
practice takes place
what if we put tyree kill
what if i had usain bolt do uh hurdles
you against bolt and hurt
i smoke you said
yeah i think that that's always that
well it's hurdles and i think sometimes
we have a hard time trying to figure
that out like you have to count you
count your steps with your when you do
hurdles
bull told me that he knows how many
steps it's going to take to get to 100
meters you know that when you do hurdles
yeah for sure it's the same uh same
rhythm step pattern um seven steps to
the first three steps in between each
hurdle and six steps off the last hurdle
so um it's the same for just about
everybody
and uh you know we do it so much in
practice and training we don't even
think about it anymore and then the same
with the hundred right i take about 44
steps when i when i do that race as well
so just like you say bull knows you know
how many steps takes him i i know
exactly as well so
what was your worst wipeout on the
hurdles
uh shoot probably training and training
um that's kind of where we go for it in
terms of like just being super
aggressive
and trying to you know improve
um you know just the time that it takes
for us to get out of the air and so
there's probably been times where i've
had a training session where i've fallen
three or four times just because i'm
being so aggressive and usually after
that happens i run a pb uh my coach
always says whenever i'm being super
super aggressive like that and training
is when i'm ready to run fast
and you know in the last four or five
years that's happened every time so pb
being your personal best personal best
yeah exactly so like probably about a
week before i ran 1284 the third fastest
time in history um in june i had a
couple sessions where i was having a
hard time staying on my feet so uh but
it always works out yeah i came back and
then ran pretty quick that next weekend
but are you a rock star when you go
to the european countries as opposed to
the united states
um
in track and field maybe i i would say
i'm pretty popular in the u.s when it
comes to track and field as well um you
know especially when i was walking
around eugene oregon uh for the world
championships but in in europe yeah
europe uh the europeans love track and
field
and the stadium and venues they are
always full with 60 70 000 people so you
know it feels pretty great it's just
like you know when i was playing college
football at austin 55 000
you know cheering for you it's that
great feeling that you know i love as an
athlete and you uh so you were there
when marcus mariota was there yep yep i
was there with marcus were you there was
herbert playing
when you got when you were still at
oregon so so technically so herbert was
a freshman by last year and he he didn't
play quite yet that season he uh
he wasn't red shirting but he was
getting like splitting uh repetition
with dakota pro cop at the time
um and then i ended up getting hurt in
the nebraska game the third game of the
season so i didn't get to play with
justin but obviously i was there and we
knew that he was going to be a guy for
sure yeah but if i would have told you
back then you know mariota is going to
win the heisman but justin herbert is
going to be one of the top quarterbacks
in the nfl
uh yeah i would have said i agree
because i we we played pickup basketball
uh over the summer and that kid's a
great athlete um and he was a great
athlete at sheldon when he when he was
in high school as well you know playing
three or four sports so you know that's
the thing about football and sports in
general like the best athletes are the
ones are gonna that are gonna thrive you
know you see kyle murray and you know um
patrick mahones and tom brady and those
guys are just great athletes so if i
said brady gets to run a 40 and you run
a hundred
uh
i think he would beat me if it was that
if it was that distance i think a race i
could beat tom brady in is if i ran like
a
100 and he ran like 70 i think i could
beat him okay
yeah what if you ran backwards
in a 40.
a hundred okay
i
yeah that'd be close i am i'm pretty
fast backwards i probably could run
close to like 12 seconds or eleven five
and a hundred backwards
but if but if you went backwards and
brady went forwards in a 40.
you're going to beat him in that right
uh that would be that would actually be
much closer the 40 would be close um i
don't want to be too hard on tom brady
he's a great athlete he's not known for
his wheels
no he's a good he's a great quarterback
devin yeah not a great one have you seen
him have you seen him play golf i'm
getting ready to play golf and it's one
of the hardest sports i've ever done
john daly plays great golf
yeah true you made a good point there
you made a good point here
i i appreciate that
hey uh congrats i think it feels like
you're getting more attention by being
dq'd than you probably would have if you
had won or competed
yeah you know it would have been nice to
win the world championships but uh
like i said in a lot of interviews the
last couple days is you know it's one of
those things it's frustrating that it
happened it's happened already and i
can't dwell on it too much because i got
uh some work to do in about a week from
now i got training camp and but could
you change the rule though do you think
that what happened to you could change
the rule i think i think it could change
the rule for sure i think there's you
know to have to have the the you know
the standard of the one tenth of a
second is good but i think you know
there has to be
some kind of margin of error and that
takes place where it's the official's
decision or you know a margin of error
on either side where the equipment can
malfunction because you know to say
something's perfect um it's just not
true
you got the olympic uh
tattoo there
yep got it right here my this is my lead
arm so all the pictures i take when i
hurdle you can see it
nice
yeah are you going to have that when you
have the football in your right arm and
you're leading with your left arm so
yeah
[Laughter]
have fun playing golf good luck with the
eagles we'll keep an eye on it we
appreciate you joining us awesome thanks
dan thanks for having me all right
that's uh devin allen the uh eagles wide
receiver and one of the great hurdlers
in america he went to two olympics
didn't meddle i think he finished fourth
was his best finish there